i love a roof gig this goes horribly i
can just
jump right off hey hey hey knock them
dead
comedy
all right just a heads up all the way up
no elevator
it's not gonna be pretty
that's my agent
look at that comedy shirt wow hey new
stuff don't judge me
it's all right it's gonna be rough but
thanks for coming fatty
i'm gonna go first but uh you got a
minute
yeah go go take a boom boom you've seen
him
uh on comedy central please give a warm
welcome to mark norman
hey thank you hey hey comedy
uh i don't know if any of you guys have
kids that sucks for you guys with the
school's being closed
it's actually good for me though cause
now i can drive by him again
hold on wait for the mta god damn it
never been heckled by a train um i just
don't
understand what's going on as much you
know corona is a lot like the stock
market
i check the numbers every day it keeps
fluctuating and i don't know what's
happening but i know i'm still losing
money
um a lot of couples here that's exciting
that guy's exhausted all right this is
good i'm
working on jokes and getting a skin
cancer
i know this feels more like summer camp
doesn't it except there's booze and
less pedophiles this is nice to be out
and everything i'm actually a quarantine
with my abuser my brain
thank you comedy
that can't be legal
[Music]
last show of the night folks up on
a roof in manhattan
we gotta get that puppy down
from the fifth floor and then we can go
up there
and bomb without further ado ladies and
gentlemen i'm bringing my brother to the
stage give it up for the one and only
mark
norman
thank you sir all right appreciate it
here we are in
epstein's fourth home this is nice sexy
place
hey hey the john wilkes booth seat over
there
all right don't shoot me good crowd
i've been watching the nba uh the stands
are empty so it's weird
the nba is weird with the empty stands
no we should do just to fill those up
let's take the racist statues and put
them in the stands
black guys like that one all right why'd
he's scared to laugh now whitey's [ __ ]
it's uh it's uh comedy's over for
honkies
you guys are fun the last crowd was a
bunch of queefs you guys are all right
just like oh i can't believe you said
that i'm like yeah i'm a comedian you
[ __ ]
all right all right
oh all right well that's one of us um
cool all right i don't like me so i'm
glad you do
went to a uh strip club in texas not too
long ago they're still open it's weird
the woman has the mask on but no
underwear
it's weird you just traded one lip for
another
you know and uh it's crazy because
you got a lady's vagina in your face but
if you're like hey if you cough on me
i'll kill you
thanks a lot i'm kevin hart you guys are
great thank you
more show you're gonna love it have a
good night comedy